John because of the Reese
musicians from our
we are obligated to read
this [ __ ] hazing is fundamentally at
odds with the ideals of Phi Sigma mu
[Music]
hazing runs contrary to our core
concepts of brotherhood and is
prohibited in all forms any activities
intended to produce harassment
embarrassed or blah blah blah blah [ __ ]
I will not be tolerated if they just
[ __ ] do this to weed out the weak
ones
show me mean business show me won't be
here I gotta be tough this is Phi Sigma
mu or gentlemen
we don't like to fight
[Applause]
but if we got a fight then we all fight
cuz we in the [ __ ] stomach
[Music]
[Applause]
get a drink [ __ ]
[Music]
listen up you guys have three hours to
finish this keg if you fail I can 100%
promise you you are gonna have to [ __ ]
this goat start the music
your mom said you thinking about bailing
on school I'm not bailing on it it's
already accepted for the fall plus fine
singers on the rushing in the fall
theater unify state I am yeah
that's awesome so what's up with Russia
anybody come out yeah of course yeah we
actually got a party on Saturday this is
Phi Sidney you four gentlemen
[Applause]
[Music]
excited on the side you're here these
are some of the best users no you're
gonna beep I say we're gonna do stuff
for their lives well they're not gonna
let you in here's my brother you need to
let me know you want to be here hello
get your ugly go to the house in 11
minutes or you're dead
[Applause]
welcome to hell we go our initiation is
a rite of passage take it take it who
was first president George Washington
sir wrong drink who shot John F Kennedy
I'm wrong drink one honorable style
there we go look I went through this
myself all right they just do this to
weed out the weak ones does this pledge
getting weirder pledges got to go
through hell otherwise what's the point
maybe she just quit did if you clip
there's another guy that couldn't hack
it I'm having sex for the first time in
my life I'm not stupid but it's not
because I mean none of it matters at all
these matters to me
but we haven't been doing anything that
every other fraternity on campus hasn't
been doing
the punic Sigma brothers do it we don't
brother do we touch we don't do we die
we are brothers do we
you